freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video einen tag persönlicher kopf
niemand geringeren als mirko kommen
gerne ins bild minister wissen überhaupt
nicht dass das viele andere minister sie
die schule gebracht hat und auch durch
die schwierigen themen des lebens
navigiert umso mehr freue ich mich dass
ich heute für dich kommen acht und die
hoffentlich ein bisschen was zurückgeben
kann wörter merken dass gary payton
absolut deshalb gibt es heute morgen
wenn ihr von man schaut verbracht hat
und das direkt mal eine auswahl treffen
ich würde dir nämlich angeht ich mach
dir ein stadtteil mit rucola mit tomate
mit käse mit du darauf san daniele
schinken mozzarella oder meine
empfehlung pocket tag wieder um alles
aber auch alles also das bis heute gut
ausgedacht sie alles außer vielleicht
wird ein bisschen überladen er ich würde
sagen wir du das in fiese wird das gut
sein denn dann nehme ich dann empfehlen
okay dann das läuft bei mir so darfst du
dich ganz entspannt zurücklehnen ich ruf
dich wird essen fertig ist dann musst du
noch gelegen dass
dieses theater ist was ganz besonderes
denn ich habe wirklich hat gerade gesagt
ernst gemeint ich wollte ja was
besonderes heute komplett von der macht
eine sehr sehr gute und wichtige arbeit
deshalb gibt es heute ganz besonders
gutes essen wenn es hoffe ich dass diese
krawatte sind extra nur zu 70 prozent
aus gebackene sind halt noch voll haben
gar kein quatsch bekommen sie nämlich
gleich auf den kontakt halbieren das
erhalten erst mal reichlich olivenöl auf
die schnitt konnten jetzt geben wir auf
die kontaktfläche durch den innenseiten
nach aus und so tauschten wir das ganze
jetzt erst mal schön
wir uns mal eine gelbe und eine rote
formate einfach nur fürs auge und ist in
russland seit ich noch vor dann haben
wir eine etwas besonderes ist so ein
bisschen schnitt presto wir
wirklich sehr sehr wild sagt und
vielleicht das ein schwerer test auf der
innenseite außenseite noch ganz weich
wie gerade eben jetzt kommen wir zum
belegen ganz wichtig auch der gesagt wir
beginnen mit mozzarella andenken
eigentlich mal zieht feuchtigkeit ins
brot aber wir haben extra angetastet mit
öl und wir machen die eigene variante
wie mozzarella wohl ohne dann kommt
formate auch schön abwechselnd auch ist
ja nicht weil ich bin richtig halten
aber prächtig jetzt kommt der rucola
drauf aber nur so schön mittig wollen
nicht dass der rubrik wird die hitze
abbekommt blieben darüber noch einmal
nicht zu knapp und hier ist so wie es
ist soweit okay als schutzschicht jetzt
wirklich charmant ist noch ganz ganz
weiche außen brauchen könnte ganze jetzt
auch und wir schließen dass sich das
dann gleich so entlastet wenn das einmal
die frauen angenommen hat dann können
wir so kaufen ich glaube es ist soweit
ich glaube der haben die ex tour
erreicht die wir haben wollen
das ist ein relaunch ist das ist
authentisch
papier mitgebracht
das ist in unserer geschichte dass es
nicht ausläuft und zwar völlig hat
irgendwelche wilden teil techniken
nordbad das werde ich jetzt einmal
probieren anzuwenden
1 1
sg birkungen dann schauen wir wie erste
hier haben wir das gute stück das habe
ihr fall ein ordentlicher april hier du
kannst dich ja schon mal damit vertraut
machen okay so ein geschenk sein wir
haben geschenke das
kann schon mal da das ist neu geholt da
bin ich schon zufrieden sein extremes
gegessen heute
riesenhunger und das ist genial
dort wird gleich gleich wirst du mich
bewerben ist aber erst wenn du ganz
aufgegeben haben willst du so entspannt
zu genießen wird so ist du hast
du auch mal was gutes ja schon gesagt in
der umgebung gibt es auch gute weine und
zur beiträge schon gerne mal aber echt
er so genießt er mit ihren flaschen
hintereinander sondern zum essen
irgendwie ganz gut passt ich bin jetzt
nicht so der weinexperte ich zeige ich
habe sofort die wir gut schmecken und
gestört werden aber dann essen genieße
definitiv ist für mich so wird schon das
hobby betrieben wird das ist gut und
gleichzeitig schlecht weil dann kannst
du dich mit gutem essen gut aus ist das
ganze erstmal ruhe auf wir sehen uns
vielleicht zu bewerten würde es schon
mal auch gegessen da bin ich schon mal
erreicht obwohl das wirklich ein apparat
ist ein apparat den fehler gemacht in
die hand zu nehmen schöne rose versucht
was hat sie denn geschenkt was hat dir
nicht gestatte mir richtig gut
geschmeckt hat war solches beschreiben
also es war halt sehr saftig was ist im
mund gehabt und das war nicht zu trocken
was er manchmal weil zusammenstellungen
der fall ist war sie ja wo ist sehr
wuchtig war hat sich jetzt nicht so
fettig an gefühl zum beispiel in hude
runter aber nicht der schein trügt aber
nicht was an kalorien das aber einfach
die gesamtkomposition die die
einzelkomponenten super
acht nämlich sehr froh jetzt frage ich
mich natürlich wenn das ganze bewertung
ist man 110 als würdest du der sache
geben
schwierig weil ich eigentlich schon
gerne trägt segen geben so gut war aber
das wäre dann doch zu einfach geht dann
muss sie jetzt
so gut wirken hat es wirklich versucht
herz version er habe nicht geklappt da
bin ich sehr sagt wo ich liebe diese art
von center serge ibaka ob deshalb kann
ich sehr gut verstehen würde dem auch
immer eine cd geben wird weil ich liebe
es her und ich hoffe das ist ja
irgendwie antreffen kann zum mittagessen
weil heute so auf denen ein leckerer tag
wenn ich dann zu sagen ich krieg direkt
mal los und gibt mir richtig viel mehr
weiter geht's mit dem mittagessen zu
sagen so wie ich habe mich da auch hier
nicht so gelassen wir haben hier einen
wunderschönen wagen p kann ja und wie
spannend es ist nämlich bei judas auf
deutschland standen dazu werden wir ein
paar groß marien knoblauch
ofenkartoffeln machen wir nehmen ein
paar kartoffeln waren sie in leicht
große mundgerechte stücke und dann hier
auch schon opa
oktober ist gar aktienmärkten die
eigentlichen gepresst hat aber rechnet
also dass das ein projekt ist das reizt
spanischen zu beginn ein wenig
backpulver in unseren top hinein und mit
kartoffeln kommen hinterher und konnten
so für zehn minuten vor ich habe jetzt
in rosmarin dein leben gemeinsam mit
knoblauch und öl in den kanton hinein
das war mehr als einmal rx hilfe weil
wie gesagt wir müssen ein bisschen
improvisiert werden das ganze jetzt mit
dem tsi fehlt dann offen ich glaube das
ganze
es verstieß sofort voll wollen wir das
ganze nicht zusammen lassen
rosmarin würden im ofen verbrennt nach
polen sprechen deshalb ebenfalls erst am
ende unseres kaufprozess ist wieder an
dann packen wir uns unsere vor gekochten
kartoffeln
retten und so ab dann können wir aber
auch unsere kartoffeln wieder in den top
10 zurück geben jetzt kommt dazu unser
aromatisiertes will jetzt passiert die
magic
jetzt werden wir der ganzen durch werfen
und man sieht vielleicht schon also
allmählich sieht man entsteht schon das
3 artiges kartoffelbrei mäßiges auf der
oberfläche
dieses aromatisierter hört ist so krank
und der rest hier haben da eine
natürlich trotzdem auch noch mal ran
gibt auch am breiten geschmack hat
geworden backblech geben jetzt der
tochter braucht man die verteilten die
mir das ganze den backofen und kümmern
uns um unseren sparen
frage in einem großzügig oben ab so dass
nur spitzen haben lässt kann man dann
vielleicht eine spargelsuppe oder
sonstwas verwenden wenig olivenöl wir
haben das ein bisschen durch das von
allen seiten benetzt ist packen wir uns
den grünen spargel geben ihnen die
pfanne
unsere starter für schöne farbe bekommen
jetzt einmal kurz angesagten party und
klein einmal oben herab lassen die der
pfanne
nehmen wir es jetzt unseren kollegen
warten wir beide maximale geht das
andere seite
mama mir eine wunderschöne finden was
weg ist ein mal kurz raus dass die
fahnen wenig abkühlen und andächtigen
sparen uns in einer man es gebe unsere
fahne wieder auf die hitze und unser
unsere titania halbiere ich jetzt einmal
gesehen auch die ist noch lange nicht
fertig werden jetzt einmal die
schnittkante versiegeln und sobald die
schnittkanten schön versiegelt sind
legen wir das wieder rein geben das zu
futtern und rosmarin satz ganz normal
funktioniert und ich mir das ganze jetzt
nicht mehr bei voller hätten sondern
weil ich bin ganz so weit und das butter
19 ist nehmen wir sie lieber um das
denkt drüber und das quasi mit der
heißen butter noch wenig abziehen und
gleichzeitig zu automatisieren rosmarin
das direkt sagen dass du den starken
noch mal hinein gibt es jetzt richten
wir das ganze noch an und da sind auch
schon fertig und kämpfen
[Musik]
endlich reagieren wir damit dessen sie
haben mit niedrigen open kartoffeln
spargelspitzen und war pikant mit was
soll ich anfangen wie auch immer du
möchtest kannst alles probieren und dann
wäre deine ersten eindruck sein okay
dann war ja mal klassisch mit den
kartoffeln haben ob sie sind sie nicht
noch zu heiß
fleisch für mehrere könnte vielleicht
das nächste mal
schön hier muss man die kamera halten
gut schneidet sich wunderbar
of praise ist da okay habt ihr mir
gesagt soll ich mal als euro wird mit
der mann habe es verstanden
ich glaube es wird zeit dass auch ein
fehler machen
den fehler machen und das ganze gleich
mal probieren jetzt bin ich sehr
gespannt das ist schon mal gutes zeichen
wobei ich jetzt weiß dass mein teller
lehre des westens werk der geist echt
jetzt das sagen heute auf jeden fall
oder gestern dass auf jeden fall auch
nicht gemacht noch mal nachhakt dann
wird's
1938 grad wollte max sagen und wie ihr
seht ist es nicht mehr merken und maxi
sitzt sondern ich wenn es ist ein
kleiner fehler unterlaufen zum ersten
mal wird dem wir zusammenarbeiten und
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch zur strafe
dieses video aufnehmen und euch
mitteilen dass die sd karte zu diesem
zeitpunkt voll war aus diesem grund ist
die gesamte bewertung von mücken und
nicht mehr dabei aber ich kann sie in
meinen eigenen ort noch genau
wiedergeben denn das steak hat ihnen
sehr sehr gut geschmeckt und auch den
spargel und auch gerade die knusprigkeit
die durch diesen schritt im topf durch
dieses mal ihren der außenhaut der
kartoffel entstanden ist hat ihm sehr
sehr gut gefallen aber es gab einen
kleinen kritikpunkt und zwar hätte man
so etwas soße noch mit dazu geben können
irgendeine art von einer barbecue sauce
gesprochen aber was hätte jegliche art
von so sein können die diesen gericht in
seinen augen noch gefehlt hat und aus
diesem grund war seine bewertung
9.8 hat sich natürlich trotzdem gefreut
und natürlich ist 9,8 alles andere als
schlecht und mit diesen positiven gefühl
ging es dann weiter zum abendessen und
ich verabschiede mich jetzt schon wieder
aus dem schnitt und entschuldige mich
nochmals für diesen kleinen fehler
kommen wir zum abendessen ich habe
nichts geringeres als eine effekte
lasagne im sinn und dafür braucht einige
zutaten wir haben hier erregt und japan
täter wir haben die mich dass gehacktes
um nicht zu sagen wir schalten beginnen
indem wir unsere pancetta hier den
schöne scheiben schneiden das muss nicht
perfekt sein danach liefen schon mal in
unseren top wurde uns eigens von dem
modell gebracht er macht heute schüler
praktika und ihr könnt ihr jetzt ein
leute dass er schlecht wir werden
natürlich auch ein wenig gemüse in woche
hinein geben dazu schneide ich hab
einmal 1000 sellerie beschneiden jetzt
karotten knoblauch zwiebel alles fertig
und werden essen kostet hier drüben
[Musik]
so wenn die ganz schade ausgelassen ist
und das ist ganz blättert man darin
schwimmt dann geben wir das ganze
einfach mal raus
und das brauche ich jetzt erstmal an
dass das auch schon farbe bekommen wenn
das der fall ist werden wir machen die
andere seite an und sagen zum nächsten
laden zu den teichen kann mir noch gar
keinen sinn ganze reduziert so sehr und
konzept durchgesetzt dass wir das am
ende abschmecken werden wir sehen jetzt
schon in unserem fall eine schöne kruste
und gebärdet und da gehen wir zunächst
einmal reduzierten des tsv wenn alles
leicht an genutzt und das können wir
auch den knoblauch dazugeben
ungefähr eine große zehe wenn alles
schön angedünstet ist dann hätten wir es
mit einem wenig tomatenmark und
tomatensaft
das ganze jetzt projekt schicken wir
ungefähr 250 milliliter wein und löschen
das ganze haben und das ganze verkochen
wird es ungefähr zur hälfte dann geht's
weiter mit dem nächsten was natürlich
auch nicht fehlen darf sind gehackten
tomaten eine kinderlose gleich mit dem
fleischsaft einfach alles was wir
beiseite gestellt hatten kommt jetzt
wieder zurück wir sehen uns gleich erst
wieder wenn alles hier schon schön ein
gekommen ist und die bloß nicht mehr
wieder zu wecken und so sieht das ganze
nach zwei bis drei stunden ausleihen
hier diese konsistenz das ist schon
somit passt richtig richtig geil mit dem
werden jetzt das schichten hier ist
unsere auflaufform geben wir ein wenig
ja gut auf den boden nicht zu viel und
verteilen das ganze so welche eine lage
im boden haben wird es zeit unsere
lasagne packen dann geben wir unsere
erste la seine platte renz ist jetzt
frische das annähernd neun wir ein
bisschen zurecht dann kommt da oben
drauf und haben schon den ganzen tag auf
unseren rekord tag zu tag damit leben
wir auf alles einmal wissen zu wollen
von dennis so aussieht haben wir als das
silicon winter braucht zieht dann auch
noch mal richtig schön je nach dem
schinken gehen wir wieder mit ein
bisschen von unserer sauce legen wir los
eine große gelage kommt als nächstes
mozzarella steht jetzt ein bisschen
dünner dass das der kiebinger ist ab
jetzt wiederholt sich alles also nochmal
ein rudel nochmal reporter nochmal
nochmal nochmals ist wie beim top player
hand
wir gehen jetzt zum schluss aber auch
eine geschichte nun will die gesamte
restliche soße in rheine richtig viel
käse drauf kann das ganze nur noch in
den osten und in der zwischenzeit
zauberin und sind jetzt hätte ich machen
das ganz klassisch armee seien der
renner zu gehen wenn du noch ein chaos
an das ist eine große gefahr beseitigt
so gehen wir das erste mal ohne viel
reden in den bug und man das ganze im
schnelldurchlauf
220 30 minuten haben wir jetzt also
daran jetzt sich aus den berufen der
schneiden direkt drei wir lassen sie
nicht groß rum sondern machen auch
direkt einen großzügigen schnitt
schneiden das erste stück von dem stück
mit man schon gut sagt
auch mit dem anrichten damals also die
lasagne ihr habt auch auf jeden fall
bisschen zeit und ein stopp schild oder
fragt so eine gute lasagne aus wir haben
die konter auf ihr film ich natürlich
tomaten so eine schöne frage haben wir
parmaschinken wir haben bei mozzarella
auch aus für mich also auch es auf jeden
fall das schöne variante
der erste nicht mein leben gegessen weil
ich mir so den mund verbrannt
wer trotzdem er hat die mutter von dem
kumpel gemacht
danach ziemlich oft eingeladen
und ich sehen uns gleich nun ich glaube
beim ganz einfach weil ich nicht so viel
geschwitzt habe ich meinen job so heiße
essen aber mir ist auch der geschmack ja
also die hürde war hoch weil ich
wirklich total gerne ist mein
lieblingsessen hat es auch oft selbst
aber ein paar dinge haben mich
überrascht und zwar primitiv also zum
einen als schinken drin war ich noch nie
an der sany geht uns aber super gute
kombination noch mit dem fleisch
harmoniert sehr gut andere sagen in
kombination mit mozzarella hervorragend
war sie ja nicht ganz so lange wie du
ständig vor hat jetzt das heißt sie die
platten sondern ein bisschen lässiger
und das habe ich auch gut war eine
rundum gelungene also ja irgendwie fühle
ich mich irgendwie so ein netter lehrer
der allen schülern eine einzige halt ist
es ist wirklich verdient also ich würde
auch hier machen wir mehr ich hoffe du
hast heute spaß total nicht ganz richtig
cool und hoffe ich kann sie auch etwas
zurückgeben wie gesagt ich bin wirklich
super richtig und super gut was für ein
kontrast deshalb schaut auch mal bei mir
vor was lernen bieten und ja ich mache
mich auf den weg nach köln danke dir
danke euch
[Musik]